Adrien Gindre votre invité ce matin un
homme qui lui aussi sachez aux questions
d'argent public et qui ne s'ennuie pas
il est président du MoDem maire de Pau
commissaire au Plan et désormais en
charge du Conseil national de la
revendication
[Musique]
bonjour François merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation on va parler dans un
instant de ce CNR d'un cible qu'il va
falloir apprivoiser d'abord un mot du
bouclier tarifaire c'est une question
d'argent également ça fait un an que le
gouvernement a décidé de bloquer les
prix du gaz de limiter la hausse des
prix de l'électricité il va être
prolongé pour 2023 mais les contours
restaient à dessiner de votre point de
vue est-ce qu'il faut continuer d'aider
tous les Français ou est-ce qu'il faudra
désormais cibler certaines catégories
vous voyez bien que c'est grâce à cette
limitation des tarifs et notamment des
tarifs du carburant que l'inflation en
France est maintenue la plus basse de
toute l'Europe
alors ça coûte très cher ça coûte 24
milliards si j'ai si j'ai bien lu le
chiffre
et donc c'est un effort énorme qui est
demandé je pense que cette limitation a
été un bon choix du gouvernement et je
pense qu'il est juste qu'on la
maintienne alors est-ce que on va est-ce
qu'il faut à la marge aménager en
ciblant lors des catégories plus
modestes les classements les
travailleurs c'est probablement plus
difficile à faire que qu'on ne peut le
dire comme ça au détour d'une phrase je
pense qu'il est que le choix de le
rendre universel ce bouquet de tarifaire
a été un bon choix certaines
collectivités locales demandent à en
bénéficier également parce que pour
certaines municipalités parfois pour
certains équipements on a vu le cas de
piscine opérée par des opérateurs privés
qui ferment parce que l'énergie coûte
trop cher et qu'on ne peut plus mener ni
politique ni maintenir les équipements
comme avant pour une ville et une
agglomération comme celle que je dirige
la peau et
l'agglomération de peau Pyrénées pour
Béarn Pyrénées c'était cette
agglomération les fluides nous coûtent
cette année 3 millions de plus
mais le mécanisme de l'inflation fait
que aussi
les rentrées fiscales suivront puisque
au fond
tout augmente et donc
ça va obliger à faire des efforts moi je
pense qu'on peut maîtriser sa dépense
d'énergie sans changer fondamentalement
les habitudes simplement en faisant
attention je prends souvent un exemple
très bête
vous avez vous allez en voiture d'un
point A à un point B
si vous décidez de lever un peu le pied
de changer de vitesse plus fréquemment
pour suivre
l'économie de la voiture pour créer
de précaution
vous dépensiez sept litres avant vous
dépenserez 6 litres après vous irez du
même point au même point à la même
vitesse
je pense que il y a j'ai souvent observé
qu'il y avait une possibilité d'économie
de 10 à 15 % sans changer
fondamentalement ses habitudes sans
avoir une aide vous mettez de l'État
vous mettez un degré de moins en hiver
dans les dans les bureaux bon ça va vous
faire ça va vous faire des économies et
puis il y a sûrement des domaines à
explorer qu'on n'a pas exploré en France
et au titre du plan je m'exprimerai
assez vite sur ce sujet on en parlera
également des questions de projection
dans quelques instants parce que bien
évidemment les perspectives sont très
importantes tout ça ça a un coût vous
l'avez rappelé on parle de milliards
dizaines de milliards en réalité à votre
place lundi l'ancien Premier ministre
Jean-Pierre Raffarin disait peu importe
aujourd'hui ce qui compte c'est la
cohésion du pays est-ce que ça veut dire
que l'équilibre des finances publiques
on le reporte à plus tard
dans l'équilibre des finances publiques
doit être de préoccupation de chaque
instant mais on doit prendre en compte
l'urgence quand on dit que la cohésion
du pays l'unité du pays le fait que les
conflits se détendent est absolument
essentiel en période de crise je pense
que c'est vrai je veux dire ce que je
crois
on est aujourd'hui en face d'une crise
mondiale pas d'une crise française d'une
crise mondiale qui va nous entraîner
dans des difficultés qui selon moi vont
être très lourds vous l'avez dit sans
précédent et pourquoi parce que le train
du monde était tiré par trois
locomotives principales la Chine
les États-Unis et l'Europe avec
l'Allemagne en particulier
à cause de la guerre en Ukraine de
l'agression que Moscou de l'agression de
de la Russie sur l'Ukraine une crise
mondiale s'est déclenchée ou a été
aggravée la Chine est en panne en
difficulté les États-Unis ont une
société qui est en explosion comme vous
le voyez tous les jours et chez nous en
Europe l'Allemagne est en difficulté à
cause de sa dépendance au gaz russe et
tout ça va
s'enchaîner s'emboîter pour faire une
crise la France est un des pays les
mieux placés ou pourrait être un des
pays les mieux placés
parce que nous avons beaucoup de chance
à condition de résoudre des questions
qui sont tendantes et sur la table
depuis longtemps on a une crise de
l'éducation nationale
on a une crise du rapport au travail on
a une probablement du rapport entre la
société et son administration voilà
trois crises qui font que nous ne
pouvons pas avoir le plein développement
dont on a besoin c'est ce sont ces
crises là profonde
qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui résoudre
alors venons-en puisque justement le
président Paul le mot de refondation
c'est un mot très important jeudi donc
sera lancé demain le Conseil national de
la refondation mais avec beaucoup
d'absents les oppositions choisies de
boycotter pour la plupart elle dénonce
un bidule hier l'ancien président
François Hollande par les mêmes d'un
machin comment faire la refondation dans
ce contexte là avec ce démarrage là oh
c'est très simple en France il y a une
tradition qui veut que ce soit la
polémique l'agressivité
l'injure qui domine les débats vous
prenez l'Assemblée nationale
si les Français entendaient ce qui se
passe dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale il entend pas parce que vous
coupez les micros enfin vous de manière
à ce que ce soit audible effectivement
les micros font toutes les chaises
toutes les chaînes de on devrait
réfléchir à ça n'est-ce pas vous avez
des débats qui sont devenus tellement
violents et insupportable par les
injures échangés que les chaînes de
télévision pour les retransmettre sont
obligés de couper les micros de
l'hémisme je pense d'ailleurs que les
Français en apprendraient davantage si
vous laissiez les micros ouverts
en tant que spectateur on voit
effectivement et on entend tout cela et
donc
cette agressivité là qui fait que on est
contre tout a priori avant que ne soit
lancé on est contre on considère que ça
n'a pas de valeur alors il faut essayer
de comprendre ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que
les forces politiques les partis
politiques qui sont installés
représentés au Parlement considère à mon
avis trompe qui doivent avoir le
monopole de la représentation le
président du Sénat il y a confusion des
rôles la loi je pense que personne n'a
jamais dit que le Conseil de la
refondation allait faire la loi la loi
c'est le Parlement l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat qui continueront à la voter
et c'est le gouvernement qui l'a
proposera comme ça que toutes les
démocraties marche dans le monde mais il
y a des millions de Français et je crois
l'immense majorité d'entre eux qui sont
préoccupés par cet avenir et par une
question
fondamental quel est le modèle que nous
construisons mais vous l'avez dit par
exemple à Édouard Philippe même l'ancien
Premier ministre a invoqué des motifs
d'agenda avoir un agenda qui n'est pas
en ligne avec les priorités du il était
étonnant il avait des il avait des
obligations de déplacement international
et il sera là lors des prochaines
rencontres et il sera représenté dans
celle-là mais vous voyez bien le l'idée
que il faudrait que tout le travail de
réflexion de proposition sur l'avenir
demeure entre les mains
de la représentation officielle
institutionnelle de ceux qui sont au
Parlement de ceux qui sont assis sur sur
les bandes des deux hémicycles
c'est ne pas se rendre compte de la
profondeur des questions que les
Français n'ont compatriotes nos
concitoyens se posent alors nous avons
tendance longtemps porté le modèle
français un modèle qui était proposé à
l'Europe et au monde
aujourd'hui
nous sommes peut-être le seul pays qui
peut à nouveau proposer un modèle encore
faut-il qu'on en parle alors sur le fond
on y vient dans un instant j'ai encore
une question juste de méthode et de
forme je disais tout à l'heure vous êtes
en charge du Conseil national de la
refondation nos camarades nos confrères
de l'opinion et quelques jours disaient
que vous seriez secrétaire général juste
pour toi clair pour noter les
spectateurs quel sera votre titre et
votre rôle dans ce traîneur je me suis
jamais intéressé au titre non j'aurais
cette responsabilité mais l'organisme je
voudrais ajouter une phrase à ce que
nous avons dit avant les forces
politiques officielles disent on viendra
pas par ce pourquoi d'autres seraient-il
amenés à parler que nous-mêmes c'est
nous qui devons parler
mais en réalité nous avons des centaines
et des milliers de demandes de français
d'organisation qui voudraient participer
et je pense tout à fait nécessaire et
légitime que ils aient droit ils aient
le droit d'accès à cette réflexion là
quelle femme ça prendra est-ce que c'est
le retour du grand débat le retour de la
convention citoyenne est-ce qu'il y aura
des nettoyant associé vous dites
certainement à participer tirés au sort
comment ça va se passer à quoi ça va
ressembler on a du mal à si on m'écoute
naturellement la seule décidé moi je
suis pas favorable au tirage au sort je
pense que les citoyens ont le droit de
participer à des événements de cet ordre
où on va parler de leur avenir pendant
longtemps vous disiez le grand débat le
grand débat c'était
une rencontre qui durait des heures dans
lequel il y avait échange entre le
Président de la République et les
citoyens de parole du président et les
citoyens
mais le lendemain on était passé à autre
chose
ce que nous allons organiser là le
conseil de la refondation dans mon
esprit et dans celui du président de la
République c'est pas du tout ça c'est
destiné à prendre le temps nécessaire
pour conduire du constat à une idée de
l'avenir donc c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
pas être pressé pour voir des mesures
issues non je pense qu'il y a des textes
de loi dans l'urgence dont nous savons
qu'ils vont être naturellement discutés
mais le Conseil national de la
refondation il s'intéresse au long terme
c'est pourquoi c'est très cohérent que
ce soit le plan la petite organisation
toute petite organisation du plan qui
qui en est la charge parce que le plan
comme le Conseil national de la
refondation
ces questions sont qu'allons-nous être
dans 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans
le CNR pour bien comprendre François
Bayrou c'est pas la préparation des
projets de loi pour la fin du
quinquennat c'est la France au-delà de
2027 alors il peut y avoir des projets
de loi pour la fin du quinquennat
j'espère qu'il y en aura mais il y aura
pas c'est pas fait pour proposer un
projet de loi pour octobre
c'est pas on se réunit et ce soir
ce qui avait été décidé à l'avant cette
annoncé et la réflexion est finie le il
y a un besoin de d'approfondir de
prendre son temps sont des questions
très importantes et ce sont des
questions civiques ce qui est en jeu
c'est notre vie pour les années qui
viennent et nos raisons de vivre moi je
voudrais qu'on y ajoute ça nos raisons
de vivre pour les pour les années qui
viennent qu'elle qu'est-ce qu'on
construit qu'est-ce que la France
si singulière dans le monde qu'est-ce
que la France construit pour l'avenir et
ça nous devons en discuter ensemble y
compris pour faire apparaître des
questions qui jusqu'à maintenant
n'apparaissaient pas je vous soumis une
question qui n'est pas directement liée
à ces enjeux mais qui est très sensible
la question de la fin de vie on a selon
certaines sources compris qu'Emmanuel
Macron voulait une loi sur le sujet et
une large consultation est-ce que c'est
un sujet sur lequel de votre point de
vue il y a nécessité de bouger ou quel
est votre conviction et comment faut
procéder le cas pour moi à titre
personnel
je pense que la loi Claisse Leonetti
adopté à l'unanimité avait fait
progresser les choses est-ce qu'elle est
appliquée je n'en suis pas certain et
ceux qui l'ont écrites n'en sont pas
certaines sont plus
est-ce qu'on peut poser la question de
de la fin de vie il y a beaucoup de
questions qui se posent à propos de la
fin de vie oui mais c'est une réflexion
éthique je suis pas sûr que ça soit
directement le sujet du Conseil national
de la refondation je pense que pour les
questions éthiques qui engagent si
profondément le la conscience qu'est-ce
que
qu'est-ce que chacun de nous voit dans
les yeux de ceux qui qui sont en train
de souffrir ou de partir qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça engage de nous au plus
profond des convictions philosophiques
personnelles religieuses parfois il y a
pas forcément besoin de bouger si je
vous comprends bien il y a une loi il
faut peut-être l'appliquer je pense que
beaucoup de gens pensent qu'il faut
bouger mais je trouve que la réflexion
doit être approfondie sur la situation
actuelle pour savoir si on pourrait la
rendre encore plus humaine
et si au fond elle était misérable
concernant Emmanuel Macron et la manière
d'exercer son mandat vous aviez
vous-même il y a quelques jours dans le
point ses propos d'une part le temps
d'une cinquième république impérieuse et
fini et un petit peu plus loin vous vous
expliquez que le président serait
davantage dans les objectifs de long
terme est-ce que c'est un constat ou
est-ce que c'est un souhait de votre
part parce qu'on a toujours vu Emmanuel
Macron très attentif aux choses du
quotidien depuis cinq ans
assez souvent avec lui
je peux vous dire que au travers des
cinq dernières années on est dans la
sixième année
sa préoccupation la plus profonde a
toujours été vers cet avenir
de long terme
qu'est-ce qui se passe en France
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans une société
comme la nôtre
qu'est-ce qui
fermente dans les profondeurs qu'est-ce
que au fond les Français attendent
qu'ils ne savent pas exprimer
ça a toujours été son ça a toujours été
son sujet c'est pour ça qu'il a fait le
grand débat par exemple
ça a toujours été une question
lancinante pour lui cette question n'a
pas pu s'exprimer dans le débat public
peut-être il aurait dû la poser dans le
débat public ça n'a pas pu s'exprimer on
a la l'occasion d'essayer je dis essayer
parce que je sais très bien si j'ose
dire je suis payé pour savoir non je
suis pas payé mais mais je suis je suis
suffisamment suffisamment averti pour
savoir que les forces qui refusent
qu'on élargisse les questions aux
citoyens
au grand courant
philosophiques et associatif du pays
ces forces sont très puissantes donc
c'est très difficile mais je suis
certain que c'est très nécessaire si
vous regardez toutes les sociétés de
nous elles sont en dessous de la mêlée
les citoyens s'exprimant sur ce qu'ils
voudraient que leur monde national et
deviennent comment vous ferez trancher
ces questions François Bayrou est-ce que
par exemple le recours au référendum
sera une possibilité pour
décider des grandes orientations d'abord
voir des textes de d'abord précisons les
questions de disons ce que nous avons à
traiter comme question
ouvrons des pistes après il y a tout le
jeu institutionnel il y a le Parlement
et Dieu sait que ça n'est pas fait le
conseil de la Fondation pour remplacer
ou se substituer au Parlement c'est
votre réponse à Gérard Larcher on l'a
bien compris
je ne l'aurais pas accepté je suis un
défenseur du Parlement ça c'est la
première chose et puis il y a des débats
plus profonds et parfois il peut arriver
que c'est débats doivent être tranchés
par référendum il y a une question
François Bayrou qui est à la fois une
question d'actualité d'urgence et de
long terme c'est bien la question des
retraites le président de la République
a fait une promesse mener une réforme il
y a beaucoup de contestations autant
dire tous les syndicats ils sont opposés
pour le moment est-ce que de votre point
de vue il faut faire cette réforme pour
faire quoi et à quel échéance je pense
qu'il est impossible de ne pas traiter
la des retraites si s'il y a des
responsables publics qui pensent
qui suffit de ne rien faire
alors c'est qu'il ne regarde pas la
réalité et qu'il ne regarde pas les
chiffres
de quoi sommes-nous menacés en réalité à
terme de quelques années on est menacé
qu'on ne plus qu'on ne puisse plus payer
les pensions c'est ça le vrai c'est ça
la vraie difficulté le vrai la vraie
menace le vrai risque est-ce qu'on peut
accepter une perspective comme ça non
on peut pas l'accepter il faut donc
prendre à l'avance les précautions
nécessaires pour que tout ceci
s'organise après tout il y a eu un texte
Marie seule Touraine a fait une réforme
qui prévoit une durée de cotisations
qu'elle l'a fait et donc mais et on
pourrait imaginer que ces adaptations
continuent au travers du temps donc vous
par exemple j'explique pour noter les
spectateurs Emmanuel Macron a dit qu'il
allait repousser l'âge légal à 64 ou 65
ans maréchal Trump elle avait allongé la
durée de cotisation ce qui est en fait
la même chose alors pour les syndicats
non parce que la CFDT vous dirait si on
veut pénaliser
est-ce que vous vous dites si on regarde
ça arrêtons-nous être un jeune une
seconde
si on regarde les deux options que vous
avez présentées du point de vue d'une
jeune fille ou d'un jeune garçon qui va
qui a 23 ans qui est à l'université qui
va entrer dans la vie active à 24 ou 25
ans si tout va bien en réalité c'est la
même chose allons-y la durée de
cotisation et déplacée de l'âge légal
vous conviendrez que c'est exactement la
même chose donc ces adaptations qui ont
commencé il y a longtemps qui ont
commencé il y a plus de 20 ans ces
adaptations elles sont nécessaires elles
doivent elles vont elles vont passer
à quelle échéance juste pour finir sur
les retraites on doit faire cette
réforme à un moment Emmanuel Macron
avait dit pour l'été 2023 ça serait
compromis je pense que le gouvernement a
l'intention d'assumer cette
responsabilité suffisamment rapidement
pour que ce soit efficace suffisamment
c'est pense que ça va commencer la
réflexion sur ce sujet pas la réflexion
le la mise en ordre de ce sujet dans
dans l'esprit du gouvernement doit venir
assez vite je voudrais terminer sur un
mot de la l'Ukraine et de la Russie en Y
a fait allusion tout à l'heure il y a
depuis plusieurs jours un débat porté
par l'opposition sur l'efficacité des
sanctions le risque qu'elle soit plus
dur pour nous à supporter qu'en réalité
pour Vladimir Poutine et à l'instant
pendant que nous étions en train de nous
entretenir Vladimir Poutine estime je
cite que les sanctions contre la Russie
menacent le monde entier et qu'il est
impossible d'isoler la Russie quelques
commentaires cela vous inspire si les
sanctions étaient inefficaces comme
l'opposition le dit est-ce que Vladimir
Poutine chercherait des mesures de
rétorsion comme couper le gaz par
exemple
tous les sanctions étaient inefficaces
donc il faut les maintenir il y a des
gens qui disent
mais en réalité ils sentir très bien son
stage
le rouble la vérité qui évidemment ces
fonctions sont dures et pourquoi
sont-elles dures parce que ce café
Vladimir Poutine est inacceptable dans
l'histoire du 20e et du 21e siècle nous
avons connu le drame suprême de la
guerre de 40 à cause d'annexion de cet
homme menace il dit qu'elle menace le
monde entier pour le plus il faut ça
signifie en effet que il va faire peser
des menaces sur le monde entier et il
faudra y résister il faut y résister il
faut y résister avec suffisamment de de
d'imagination pour partager la charge
avec nos voisins et pour améliorer cette
la situation relative de la France dans
cette dans cette
circonstance historique merci beaucoup
François Raud d'être venu à la veille
donc du lancement du Conseil national de
la refond